-Welcome to the show.
-Thank you for having me.
-It is --
It is great to have you on.
I'm a big fan. I --
-Me too. I must say...
-Yeah.
-...it's particularly nice
to be on because I've got
a soft spot for the show.
One of my kids, a few years ago,
sent me a clip
of you and Bradley Cooper
irretrievably breaking --
breaking up.
-Laughing so hard.
-Like, yeah.
-That was --
We cut that down actually.
-It's just joyful.
Well, the whole segment.
-The whole segment? Well,
we actually even cut that down.
-You walked away at one point.
-We laughed for 25 minutes.
It was terrible.
It was very unprofessional.
-There's one moment, you're --
you're on the floor, face down.
-I'm wiping my tears.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-He's not --
He's banned from the show.
Yeah, he actually is.
Not allowed back.
-Good. Ban him.
-Yeah, and we only have
professional actors now
on the show.
-Yeah, this is -- yeah.
-You went to a very prestigious
drama school in the
Royal Academy of Dramatic Art
in London.
-I did. A long time ago, yeah.
-Yes. We actually
found your headshot...
-Did you?
-...from when you were
in that -- Yeah.
Tell me about this guy.
What was he all about?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. Wow.
-I look -- I look like
a sort of nervous Tarzan.
I look like a weird --
And there's some sideburns...
-Yeah.
-...going on there.
-I like his vibe.
I like his style.
He's like --
-Yeah.
-He -- He was --
He was going out.
He wanted to get hired
for anything?
What was he wanting to do?
-Yeah.
It's a bit like, "Pick me.
Not -- Don't really pick me."
-"Pick me, but don't."
-"Don't -- Yeah."
-Yeah.
-Did -- This is --
Did it feel like you were
going to nail it at the time?
Did you go,
"Yeah, I've got this"?
-No. No.
Just terror. Just total
uncertainty and terror.
It never -- It doesn't
really end, that feeling.
-This guy went --
This guy went to win numerous
awards for "Succession."
I mean, come on.
He's beloved now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
BAFTA. BAFTA winner.
Not too shabby.
I mean, multiple,
multiple awards.
I mean, has this --
has this gone to your head?
-Uh, no, it's sort of -- No.
It's very nice. It's very nice.
The Emmy --
The Emmy night was very scary.
-Why? Just --
-Just 'cause you're sort of
normalizing everything all
the time and trying not to be --
You know,
'cause there's Ben Stiller
and there's Oprah Winfrey,
and you're trying to
make it normal, and actually
it's just horrifying.
-Yeah. How does -- how does --
-Really scary and --
-How does the cast deal with you
now that you're
a multiple award winner?
-They don't speak to me anymore,
which is fine.
They don't -- Yeah, yeah.
No, they're lovely.
They're lovely.
-Yeah? They do? Yeah.
How did you come up
with the voice of Tom?
Because we all noticed
you're not American.
-Well, yeah.
I'm not an American.
-No. That gets the award
right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That gets the award.
Unbelievable.
-Yeah.
It's really -- It's difficult.
Sarah Snook, who's Australian,
who plays Shiv,
she and I have sort of
accent days where we're like,
"We can't do this.
We just can't do it."
Everything sounds weird.
"New York" is very hard to say
in an American accent.
-How -- "New York"?
-Yeah, it just kind of
turns into sort of
"New Yarrrk. Nyork. N'york."
It's like a whole --
Like, it's really --
Like, it's really hard.
-"Let's go -- go to Nyork."
-"Yeah, going to Nyork."
-"Let's go to Nyork."
-"I'm an American,
and I go to Nyork.
-"Live from Nyork,
it's 'Saturday Nert.'"
-That's right.
But there are certain --
If I look --
But if I look at the --
If I look at Nick Braun,
who plays Greg,
I suddenly think,
"Oh, there's Greg."
And it's all -- it's just --
Yeah, his sort of face
tells me what to do.
And my voice goes very high with
Sarah, partly through fear --
Tom's fear of shiv.
-Yeah, of course.
-So I start -- Yeah.
It's sort of --
It's very like, "Honey, honey,
honey, no, no. Alright."
And so then I sort of
find my level, yeah.
-Well done.
I want to talk about your
new miniseries on Britbox.
Britbox, by the way, you can
download on anything you have.
Apple TV or whatever it is.
It's a streaming service.
This is based on a true story.
Anyone who's not familiar
with John Stonehouse,
can you set this up?
-So, John Stonehouse
was a British M.P.,
a Member of Parliament,
in the '60s and '70s,
and he was kind of a rising star
in the Labour Party in Britain.
And through various
unfortunate events,
he has a terrible,
complicated love life
and he gets in terrible
financial trouble.
And he's spying, badly,
for the Czech secret service.
And, anyway -- And it all
becomes too much for him.
And he decides
to fake his own death.
-So he fakes his own death.
-Yeah, he leaves his wife
and children and he flies
to Miami on a business trip,
on a so-called "business trip,"
and he swims --
leaves his clothes on the beach
and a passport
on top of his clothes
and swims into the sea.
And then swims along
the coast a bit and comes out
and then flies to Australia.
-Yeah. Oh, Australia?
-On a fake -- with a fake
passport with a new identity.
In the days when it was easier
to fake your own death,
he does it.
-Yeah, yeah, if -- We all know.
We all can relate to that.
Yeah, of course, yeah.
-So -- And I didn't know
anything about this guy.
So it was just a fascinating,
bonkers story.
-Yeah.
-Amazing.
-Your wife in real life,
Keeley Hawes,
plays your wife in the show.
-Yeah.
-Is that difficult to do or...?
-It was lovely.
-It was great?
-It was lovely, yeah.
It was really good.
It was so nice.
-Yeah.
-I mean, yeah, they have
an odd relationship in the show,
and she sort of sees through
his shenanigans.
But it was just great to play.
It was nice.
Well, you said before
that your kids have never --
no real want to see --
-Desire to see us
on screen, ever.
Not really.
-But even --
even after the awards that
you've gotten and everything?
-Not really. No.
-But then you said,
"Well, maybe when they're
teenagers, they'll get into it."
-That's what I thought.
-Yes.
-Yeah, no.
-They are teenagers.
-They are.
-And they still don't.
-They're like 18 and 16.
And they --
they have other things to watch.
-What do they watch?
-There's a lot of --
There's a lot -- Other stuff.
I don't know, yeah.
-Anything but you.
They don't want
to see Mom and Dad.
-Not really.
-No, okay, yeah.
Well, they should watch
"Stonehouse"
because Mom and Dad
are really good in it.
-Thank you.
-I just want to say that, yeah.
Please watch -- Download Britbox
and get watching.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Matthew Macfadyen and
Keeley Hawes in "Stonehouse."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-What are you doing?
-It's private.
-I -- I thought we didn't have
secrets from one another.
-It's something
for your birthday.
-But that's...two months away.
♪♪
Hm.
-That's how you do it. Come on.
Matthew Macfadyen, everybody.
"Stonehouse" premieres
on Britbox January 17th.
We'll be right back with
stand-up from Ralph Barbosa.
Stick around, everybody.